[موسيقى]
بعد التوحد والسكتات القلبيه ودماغيه
ومخاطر توريث فرط النشاط دراسه جديده من
جامعه ولايه اوهايو تجد ان الباراسيتامول
يزيد من سلوك المخاطره الدراسه التي نشرت
نتائجها مجله علم الاصابع عززه لائحه
الخطيره لاستهلاك المسكن الاكثر شعبيه
والمتوفر في الصيدليات اذ يبدو ان الدواء
الذي يباع الانفاق واسع تحت اسماء تجاريه
مختلفه يزيد من سلوك المخاطره في العقار
بحسب الباحثين يجعل الناس يشعرون بمشاعر
سلبيه اقل عندما يفكرون في انشطه محفوفه
بالمخاطر مثل القفز بالمظلات والتعبير عن
راي غير الشعبي في الاماكن العامه فلا
يشعرون بالخاص
[موسيقى]
مسكن الالم اكثر شيوعا وشعبيه في العالم
الدراسه تقول انه يزيد من سلوك المخاطره
دقيقه هذه الدراسه
على الادويه التي تصرف بدون وصفه
هو محاوله الحد من الافراط في استخدامها
عشان هي يمكن شرائها بدون وصفه طبيه بس
نتكلم على الدراسه دي بالتحديد على زياده
نسبه المخاطره او التهور عند الناس اللي
ممكن تستخدم الباراسيتامول فهي كان دراسه
بسيطه على بعض الطلاب الجامعيين اللي
بيحاولوا يشوفوا تاثير الباراسيتامول على
همم سلوك المخاطر الموجود عندهم بس يمكن
لو احنا ركزنا في الملك هو همم مركب
الباراسيتامول يمكن خطورته الاكبر على
مستوى بعض الاعراض الجانبيه اللي ممكن
تحصل منه نتيجه الافراط في الجرعه زي
تاثيره على وظائف الكبد احيانا لا قدر
الله بيوصل للفشل الكبدي نتيجه الافراط في
استخدام الباراسيت جرعه عاليه ومع ذلك هو
ما زال يعتبر من اامل المسكنات لا يمكن
استخدامها همم
على مستوى العالم كمان كالمستوى همم
بعد اليوم واذا في حال اثبتت هذه الدراسه
راح تصيروا خلاص انه اذا حدا بده يشتري
براسيتامول او اي الانواع لازم يكون وصفه
طبيه هالمره
يمكن من قبل كده من حوالي 40 50 سنه من
ساعه ما اثبت تاثيره كاعراض جانبيه على
مستوى الكبد او غيره وهو ده يمكن الخطر
الاكبر يعني بس طبعا باي تايم انت بتلاقي
فيه اعراض جانبيه جديده بتحصل ومشكله
البارز لان الامهات بتدي له كل الاطفال
همم لما بيسخنوا همم في اي دور بارده او
غيره فبالتالي بيبقى ساعات في افراد في
الجرعه وده اللي بياثر بعد كده همم بنشوف
دلوقت مثلا نسبه الاطفال اللي بيجيء لهم
اعراض فرط التوحد في اهم حاجه بالنسبه
للامهات ان ما تستخدم مش عا- زي ما بيقول
في مصر على الفاضي على المليان يعني الطفل
حاولي تستخدمي الاساليب الاخرى اللي تقلل
درجه الحراره وتخلي استخدام الباراسيتامول
عند الحاجه القصوى وده امامنا همم لطفلك
بصفه عامه
[موسيقى]